[Music]
[Music]
good afternoon and welcome to the sixth
annual space grant public lecture
sponsored by the Massachusetts Space
Grant consortium our speaker this
afternoon has traveled further than
anyone has or most likely will ever
traveled to give this lecture Jack
Schmitt went to the moon and back and is
going to tell us a little bit about that
now there are for the benefit of those
of us in those in the audience who don't
have any gray in your hair put yourself
back into the mindset of the American
population in the late 60s and the
excitement that was generated throughout
not just in the mi t--'s and the
Harvard's and the Caltech stand the
staffers of the world but throughout the
community about them the excitement of
preparing for probably the boldest human
space exploration of all time it of
course reached its initial excitement in
the footstep that everybody remembers
with Neil Armstrong and our alumnus Buzz
Aldrin and he continued on through a
science gathering activity which has in
many ways never been repeated in the
history of the space program culminating
with the first scientist to walk on the
moon our speaker today who was also and
this is somewhat ironic to look back
upon it the last man to walk upon the
moon Jack Schmitt who was a good friend
to many of us here at here in Cambridge
began work as a geologist and it had a
very promising career as a geologist
when he was selected by NASA as an
astronaut to train for the Apollo
program and performed the way many of us
had always hoped scientists and
engineers in space would perform in the
course of his exciting
exploration of the moon beyond that
after return and after some important
work with the with the space agency he
went on to another challenge in many
ways just as great and that that is trot
in attempting successfully to a great
extent to have his ideas carried forward
to fruition for the benefit of all of us
as a member of the United States Senate
a senator from his home state of New
Mexico and since that period of time
Jack has remained active in a number of
areas including the space arena where we
continue to bump into him I'd be happy
to say we're usually on the same side of
the of the vigorous argue vigorous
arguments that ensue and what we have
asked senator Harrison Schmitt to do
today in his talk a trip to the moon is
talk about not only what it was like but
of what could it can be like for the
next generation senator Schmit
[Applause]
well thank you very much Larry and I I
appreciate the introduction and I also
appreciate appreciate the opportunity to
speak once more at MIT on this subject I
think the last time was about 20 years
ago and it was to a roomful of
geologists nurse scientists from MIT and
Harvard so I don't think any of those
people are here and so I'm probably not
repeating anything I might have said and
I don't have to worry about being
consistent what Larry is exactly right
what I would like to do is to take you
on a trip to the moon I'm not going to
spend a lot of time getting you back
usually for many offenses I do spend
some time getting everybody back but we
won't worry about that today I because I
briefly summarize the the first-order
understanding of this small planet that
we gained as a consequence of the Apollo
program an extremely important
consequence and not one that was
anticipated by John F Kennedy when he
said he wanted he challenged the nation
to go to the moon and return safely to
earth but one which in the in the
process of implementation of that
challenge we realized a great deal could
be done and indeed a great deal was done
also in the at various points in all of
this you'll hear me talk a little bit
about what I think the future may hold
not only for the moon but in its now
increasingly symbiotic relationship with
the earth and ultimately with the human
settlement of the solar system in
general so with that brief introduction
if we could have the the lights down and
the first slide that's up to me I guess
did it go
there we go and and if the speaker light
could come down I think the slides would
you've all seen me so you don't need to
see me through this little thing can I
control that or could we have the
speaker light down maybe we can't do
that at any at any rate we begin these
trips to the moon in the late 60s and
early 1970s from the Kennedy Space
Center and here you see the Saturn 5
rocket to be used by the Apollo 17
mission moving away from its assembly
building the Vehicle Assembly Building
towards the launch pad it is still the
largest rocket that has ever been used
to put human beings in space 364 feet
high the basic fully fuel weight was 6.2
million pounds and the five big engines
in the first stage developed 7.5 million
pounds of thrust now the space shuttle
approaches those numbers but does not
reach them and it was indeed exactly
what we needed for this mission a truly
remarkable accomplishment is putting
this system together and one which
worked with extraordinary reliability
each time we demanded something of it by
the way the that Vehicle Assembly
Building is now fully utilized even
unlike in the Apollo program fully
utilized by the activities of the space
shuttle program this is just an
alternate view of the Saturn 5 looking
from the bottom up those of you who can
see in the lower right hand corner the
upper torso of a man will get a feeling
for scale here it's quite a large
vehicle that D on the Fen left-hand fin
is about 5 feet high I would suspect
really awesome not only from the bottom
but from the top here now looking across
the top and the launch escape rocket
that is attached to our capsule
that you can see there the cone-shaped
capsule at the top of the rocket looking
back towards that Vehicle Assembly
Building that I mentioned earlier I
think you generally don't need this but
that's the the building out there we
were on our way out to the launch pad at
this point moving at less than a mile
per hour on this huge machine they call
the we call the crawler by the way that
the crawlers are still used to transport
the space shuttles out to the launch pad
now we have many different kinds of
training thousands of hours of course
and computer driven simulators that
prepared us for the actual flight
portions of our mission but also we had
things like survival training and here
you see some very young and skeptical
looking astronauts learning about the
care feeding and preparation of boa
constrictor in at an Air Force stationed
in Panama at Mitchell MIT graduate is in
that picture PhD I don't know whether
Charlie Duke was he yeah well Charlie's
behind the boss so you might not be able
to tell that but I remember that he was
behind the boy now we also had science
training and as a consequence of the
efforts of many people throughout the
country including Bill brace here at MIT
and some Harvard professors and some
Caltech field geologists we finally
develop for the last three missions a
comprehensive earth science training
program that prepared two pilot
astronauts about as well as one I think
could ever expect to prepare these
really already outstanding observers to
systematically collect samples establish
their context by through verbal
description and photography and to give
us the basis for that first-order
understanding of a second planet that I
mentioned earlier
here you see Gene Cernan the commander
of the Apollo 17 mission and yours truly
in an exercise near Flagstaff Arizona
science exercise we actually each time
we went out for the most part actually
in profiles
but working on the geology the science
of real earth problems
why Jean felt in this context it was
necessary we're checkered pants I'm not
sure he was a any I guess he would still
say is a Navy test pilot and that might
explain the checkered pants Jean also
was the talker on the crew believe it or
not and here you see us in an exercise
involving our actual flight lunar roving
vehicle we were checking out all the
what they call the fit and function of
it in our pressure suits and Jean had
come up with something that excited him
and it obviously put me to sleep
but ultimately on December 7th Florida
time in 1972 we left the earth with the
with a spectacular night launch I am
told having just seen discovery launch
at night I can get some feeling now for
what it was like but of course I missed
that and inside the capsule we were
subjected to an not very heavy G's
because the initial acceleration is
quite slow but extraordinary heavy
vibration in in fact the the instrument
panel switch panel in front of me as I
was lying on my back was vibrating so
much that I could not read the dial so
it was always some question in my mind
why did I go through all those launch
abort simulations when I wasn't going to
be able to read the dials during that
period of time now on the other hand had
we actually had to abort for some
serious problem I'm sure my adrenaline
adrenaline would have focused my eyes as
rapidly as they were the panel was
vibrating and everything would have
worked out just fine
it actually took 14 seconds to reach a
point about like this go the length of
the rocket it took 2 minutes and 45
seconds to get to a full acceleration on
the first stage which was about 4 G's
that was the greatest acceleration we
had during the launch but at that point
we of course had reached the limit of
fuel in the first stage rocket we we
turned it off stage that is dropped it
off into the Atlantic and then reignited
the second stage rocket in a sequence
that went from four G's to a - one and a
half G's as that whole stacked actually
unloaded a little bit - a plus one and a
half G's and now love that happen in
just over a second now that gets your
attention
you know these checklists bang back and
forth and you know why you're strapped
into your your couch because otherwise
you'd be banging back and forth at the
same time but after we went through the
second stage ignited a third stage which
was actually restartable because we will
see that we're going to use it again the
s4b we were in orbit after as I recall a
little under 10 minutes and they had a
chance to briefly look at some
spectacular views of this planet Earth
here the South Atlantic and its cloud
patterns the coast of Africa and the
sand dunes and on over the Kalahari
Desert looking down at these Frost's
like patterns of actually turn out to be
burn scars
apparently fire set by the local
inhabitants to improve the the grazing
for the next season into the over the
Indian Ocean in the Magnificent
thunderheads that one can see there
almost anytime particularly at the
Intertropical Convergence zone and then
to a sunset oh actually I'm sorry these
are the atolls of the Great Barrier Reef
I believe in near Australia and the
turquoise blue by the way shows up
extremely distinctly from way way out
into space quite a remarkable contrast
with the deeper blue of the oceans it
took 90 minutes to go around the earth
we were traveling at about 18,000 miles
an hour we've made to two trips around
the earth to make sure all the
spacecraft and rocket systems were ready
to go to the moon and indeed they were
and so at the end of our second trip and
after passing through a Sun Sun
set I believe in this case we ignited
the third stage rocket the s4b began to
accelerate over about a five minute
period to twenty five thousand miles an
hour so it threw a sunrise the most
spectacular sunrise I've ever seen until
we were indeed on our way to the moon in
a nearly perfect trajectory the at that
point we undocked the main spacecraft
the command and service module America
was its name from the the s4b rocket
moved away a little bit turned around
and then moved back in in order to
extract the lunar module challenger
which you see here tucked away and
folded up in the end of the rocket this
is the docking port and tunnel we'd
retract that so we all could go to the
moon together now those bright spots
that you see around the s4v are pieces
of ice actually ice that had condensed
from the atmosphere in Florida on the
cold fuel and oxidizer tanks of the s4b
and came off when we shut down the
engine for the last time those are
probably what my good friend and former
colleague John Glenn thought were
fireflies over Australia now he is the
Democratic senator from the state of
Ohio and that might explain that little
anomaly
the s4b side way just so you can see
what it looked like as it coasted with
us at 25,000 miles an hour initially to
an impact on the moon we actually this
became a science experiment at this
point because we already had in place a
seismic net from the previous missions
and the s4b was a source of seismic
energy which we directed in an
appropriate location for science and
seismology on the moon it got I can't
remember now I think it impacted after
we had gone behind the moon as you'll
see in a few moments but at once we had
the Challenger in tow we were able to
look back at this beautiful planet
rapidly receding from us here are still
filling the window but eventually not
even doing that and we were able to take
this very very popular picture of the of
our dear planet Earth showing the entire
continent of Africa most of Antarctica a
hurricane our Typhoon going ashore here
on India and on the subcontinent of
India Mediterranean there and the inner
the Front's that are circling around
Antarctica very nicely shown really a
spectacular picture and I'm we're all
very proud of it it is still the most
requested image from the NASA archives
as you might expect the worst use of
this picture that I have ever seen was
in a and I'm even going to mention the
name a TWA in-flight magazine where it
wasn't good enough like this and so they
moved Australia over here
[Laughter]
there is Australia this was taken about
a day and a half after the picture I
just showed you the year we were in now
a lunar reference trajectory as it was
called and that the earth was turning
beneath us once every 24 hours and going
through a slow phase transition as you
see here not nearly as full and we're
here looking at the South Pacific you
see how brilliantly Australia is a
desert beacon shows up and indeed you
could see the deserts and particularly
Australia very clearly from the moon and
identify them the number of things I
being an amateur meteorologist I fill
the transcripts with all sorts of
forecasts descriptions and forecasts as
we went towards the moon for three and a
half days I'm sure I put everybody in
the Mission Control Center to sleep but
I enjoyed myself there wasn't much else
to do as you travel out toward space
except make sure you didn't get into
trouble this is a typhoon and the
Philippine Sea and those spots right
there are thunder heads on each of the
Philippine Islands another typhoon was
developing around wom which nobody knew
about him we were able to tell the world
about and particularly the air force was
interested because they had recovery
airplane flying in that REIT in that
area in support of our mission this
speckle point is an interesting
phenomenon and actually is a way in
which visually you can tell what the sea
state is it's always brighter for
example near the shore of near
continental Shores because of the
increased wave activity at that point if
you look carefully that's China up there
and in Southeast Asia the this front is
just clear Japan Japan's not quite so
clear and obvious at this point and the
earth continues to recede about three
days out so we had another view of
Australia but at this point we became
increasingly aware of a dark looming
shape blocking out the star field as
well as the the earth itself when we
headed towards orbit and there you see
the mountains of the
moon across our dear planet Earth again
the first sunrise that we had in the
spacecraft behind the moon is shown here
actually it's a it's a sunset on the
moon we were in a retrograde orbit so
that we when we landed on the other side
of the moon if they buy in the valley of
taurus-littrow we would have the Sun to
our back it made just for better
visibility of course then flying into
the Sun itself this illustrates a number
of properties of the the moon that are
of interest for one thing you see
absolutely no evidence of an atmosphere
off there on the horizon the vacuum at
the surface of the Moon is about 10 to
the minus 12
Torr basically no atmospheric gases at
all although there is a very small and
and measurable amount of atmosphere the
there's no oxidation of iron minerals so
you get none of the colorful features
that we're used to here on earth but you
do have a beauty of contrasts which this
picture and others I think will help to
illustrate now the reason I show this
picture somewhat out of sequence I
actually took this on the way home just
after we left lunar orbit but it's to
give you an indication of where we were
going the valley of taurus-littrow which
you'll see more of in a moment it was in
the cut through a radial valley cutting
through the ring of mountains
surrounding this relatively young
circular basin called serenity us
serenity Odyssey is 500 kilometers in
diameter somewhat bigger than Crisium
which you see here but not quite as big
as tranquil a TARDIS which is the more
irregular basin here Apollo 11 Neil
Armstrong and Buzz Aldrin landed right
there that's tranquility basis in that
vicinity of the moon our landing as I
say it was somewhat north of that the a
better view a close-up view of the
valley of taurus-littrow is shown here
it's that dark Bay like indentation here
it's about 35 miles Y long about four
and a half miles wide and those
mountains on either side
seemingly somewhat subdued our rise to
7,000 feet at their highest points so we
landed in this valley or a point about
right there
in a valley deeper than the Grand Canyon
of the Colorado truly a remarkable
demonstration once again of the
navigational techniques that had been
developed by the Apollo program and in
particular with the assistance and and
innovation and imagination of the Draper
laboratory which then was the MIT
instrument that I forgotten when they
were spun off somebody tells was after
that when they were spinning I am
privileged to serve on the board of the
Draper lab now so I I get to come back
and thank them as many times as I can
remember to do it the this picture was
taken from about a hundred miles away
this one from about 15 miles away and in
a somewhat lower altitude and we were
only about 10 nautical miles above the
surface at this point the landing site
is going to be there this spot right
here is the other spacecraft Ron Evans
who was the third man on our crew was
alone at this point since this picture
was taken from the lunar module as we
prepared for our last orbit and descent
to the valley of taurus-littrow ron was
about a mile ahead and a little bit
below us preparing to get out of the way
of our descent on the next orbit this
mountain here is the highest mountain in
the that borders the valley again
something over 7,000 feet high the
looking straight down on the valley is
is of interest we landed right there and
those of you are close enough will see a
dark shadow or spot there that is the
shadow of the lunar module Ron actually
took this picture as he passed overhead
while we were working on the surface
there's a light-colored spot around the
DC area here that was caused by the
sent effluence just altering the optical
properties of the surface we've never
been able to detect any any impregnation
of the effluence of the decent engine
just a modification of the surface
texture this feature here this plume
like deposit is a the remains of an
avalanche that came off the side of the
South Massif that high mountain I
pointed out earlier very probably in
response to material thrown over 2,000
kilometers from the crater Tycho in the
southern part of the moon those of you
who look at the moon once in a while
will know that name it's one of the
younger bright halo craters by trade
craters on the moon and it appears as if
one of its rays comes all the way up
here to across Stars literal and we are
suspecting that that Avalanche was
triggered by that by the impact of that
secondary debris the ages as far as we
can tell the age of Tycho and the age of
this about 30 million years work out to
be approximately right so that's the the
present working hypothesis that we we
indeed had evidence or worked on an
avalanche caused by Tycho the are
traverses the first excursion we worked
primarily around the lunar module doing
deploying the the Apollo of science
package the alsep about 300 meters ahead
of the rock of the Challenger we also
sampled around craters in this area the
second excursion though we we got going
early we headed all the way out here
about seven kilometers to that point
right there and worked our way over to
this dark crater where we found the
orange soil and then back to the lunar
module and the third excursion was over
here to visit some big boulders you'll
see in a moment the fact is I think it's
right there and and then back to there
so we traveled about 35 kilometers in
the lunar rover which you all show you
in a moment and collected about 250
pounds of samples several thousand
photographs and generally had not only a
great enjoyable time but a fairly
productive scientific mission as well
this is the first view I had out the
right-hand window of the Challenger
after landing it's a view over a fairly
typical dark mari surface of the moon
the scattered blocks of basalt and the
ground up and pulverized basalt that
makes up what we call the lunar regolith
that debris layer or sometimes called
soil layer that covers the moon in this
valley it averages about 9 meters thick
it is the regolith of the moon is the
source of many potential resources we'll
talk about in a few moments including an
energy resource a light isotope of
helium called helium-3 that is a nearly
ideal environmentally as well as
efficiency ideal fuel for nuclear fusion
the the metallic object there and the in
the foreground is one of sixteen small
restartable rockets that we use to
control the attitude of the spacecraft
when we were in flight the far edge of
the valley there say that point right in
there is probably about four miles away
something like that now you have to take
my word for these distances and sizes
and things like that because they're
there no telephone poles or trees or
houses or anything that you can use for
for reference and indeed astronauts
almost invariably underestimated the
distances and it was it like sometimes
you do when you drive in the western
United States when the air is clear you
and they have no clear reference of size
you will do the same thing
the Challenger our home away from home
on the moon really an excellent camp not
only did the descent stage the lower
half of the Challenger contain
everything that we could need for our
particular mission including the lunar
rover and the science packages and even
our food and film the ascent stage was
really a very good camp sleeping in
one-sixth gravity that you have on the
moon is very comfortable we had hammocks
that provided a very good rest
not enough gravity to make you want to
toss and turn but just enough to feel
like you were lying on something rather
than floating the food was reasonably
good certainly better than I've had in
some of my field camps that I've worked
in as a field geologist no hot water we
had hot water and the other spacecraft
the America but we did not have hot
water in the lunar module the that would
just was not provided for and was not
really necessary
that for three days on the moon and
maybe most important for a geologist and
maybe some others there are no black
flies or mosquitoes to bother them this
picture was taken from about 75 meters
away now you may have already wondered
did we ever feel homesick well my answer
is no because any time I wanted to see
home I could just look up over the here
the lunar module or the nearest mountain
and see the earth only 250,000 miles
away communications were excellent just
outstanding though we never had any
communication problems of any of any
significance whatsoever and we worked as
if almost as if we were working anywhere
else you could imagine here on earth a
well dressed astronaut
where's what you see here the spacesuit
of the backpack the emergency oxygen
supply there and the man inside weighed
in this case about 370 pounds earth
pounds but on the moon that would only
be about 61 pounds mass didn't change of
course but the weight was quite
different and so it was really quite
easy to move around you had to watch
yourself a little bit your center of
gravity was displaced about two inches
towards the back because of the weight
of the backpack and and you you'll see
us leaning forward in order to
compensate for that that was very
natural to do although Charlie Duke went
when he was on the moon on Apollo 16
decided to demonstrate what it was like
to
jump straight up and he forgot that his
center of gravity was displaced and so
he rotated out of the view of the camera
and everybody got a pretty good lift
pretty good laugh out of that the if you
ever wonder why astronauts are whistling
and singing quite a bit while they're
working on the moon it's because it's so
much easier than training in one gravity
it really is we worked we were basically
pressurized for almost ten hours each
for each excursion that we each of the
three excursions and the only part only
the only muscles that really became
fatigued were your forearm muscles and
the hand muscles and that's because the
glove was just purely a pressure glove
and it was every time you wanted to move
you had to squeeze against that pressure
3.5 psi and and that was be like
squeezing the tennis ball continuously
every time you wanted to do something
you had to squeeze a tennis ball to do
it that fatigue these forearm muscles no
matter what you had done to prepare
yourself physically there was just
nothing you could do after about a
half-hour so you would finally realize
what your steady-state capability was
and you'd proceed from there but the
overall loss of efficiency as a
consequence of that was significant and
I hope that someday and maybe some
engineer from MIT will we'll figure out
how to engineer a glove that more
closely duplicates the normal dexterity
of the human hand that's one reason why
we put human beings in space is to have
that hand attached to a to a
supercomputer called the brain and
something that we haven't yet been able
to duplicate to any other way the rake
that you see there was just one of the
many tools that we had for collecting a
particular style of sample small samples
out of this lunar regolith and but you
also see I'm not going to the trouble to
grasp that rake I just rest it against
my hand again anything you can do to
keep from using your forearm muscles you
would do gene cernan is testing out the
lunar rover in this case it weighed
about 400
earthbounds without any without us or
anything else on it worked extremely
well had four-wheel independent drive
and four-wheel independent suspension
you could had front and rear wheel
steering you could do either direct or
Ackermann steering with it just worked
remarkably well had no problems with the
dust because all the joints and bearings
were sealed hermetically so the dust
never was able to penetrate into them
serve this extraordinarily well on all
three of the missions that it was used
on getting on the lunar rover was was
not particularly difficult once you
learn the tricks you stand at the side
jump up into the vacuum with a little
bit of leftward translation and hope
that you came down on the seat assigned
to you
commanders tend to get upset when you
come down and their seat is a little bit
like professors I guess if they find you
in their chair somewhere they're paid to
get upset so we don't worry much about
that one thing that lunar module pilots
are paid to do though is to repair the
fenders broken by commanders on each of
our Rover missions the commander's
succeeded in breaking a fender off and
lunar module pilot very quickly we're
instructed on how to repair it here you
see unneeded photo maps taped together
with you guessed it gray duct tape it's
held the rover together just like it's
probably holding this building together
by now and it worked very well and the
reason this was important it wasn't just
a trivial exercise is that in one-sixth
gravity this debris when you're driving
would travel just far enough up the
wheel to give you a forward roostertail
and you'd be driving into your own dust
if you did not have something to break
that trajectory this picture you have to
look at because I like to look at it I
never tire of it it not only brings back
the memories of the desert like quality
of the valley of trial at all or any
place on the moon really but it it it
Ellis traits the just the general nature
of what we were doing the lunar rover
often the in the middle distance the
basalt boulders around a crater that's
actually on the rim of a crater 600
meters in diameter
the largest in the immediate area
probably a crater formed by those taiko
secondaries we're just not sure okay
now we're going to stand on the north
side of the valley the next few pictures
will be a rough panorama of looking from
the east here towards the south this
actually looks along the path we flew to
come into the valley this picture over
the top of a very large boulder if yours
truly for scale actually actually
includes the lunar module that spot
right there is a lunar module about
three and a half miles away with that
again lightened patch of material and
the right at the top of the regolith of
quite visible at this at this point
these boulders are made up of fragments
of rock they're called bretch --is
that's a term that geologists used for
rocks made up or fragments of other
rocks
it actually prob almost certainly formed
as a result of the huge impact that
created the Serenity das bacon basin the
at whose edge we had landed and it had
rolled down the mountain from about
kilometer and a half away down about a
26 degree slope until it hit a break in
slope here we were on about a 20 degree
slope and it broke into five pieces but
you can see here the the the near edge
of that of the trench the boulder track
if you will that it made as it rolled to
a stop my footprints are coming down
they're out of sight and up the other
side those footprints will stay in
recognizable form for about a million
years so if you want to leave your
footprints in the sands of time this
isn't a bad place to do it certainly far
more certain than going to Washington
view of that South Massif the highest
mountain in the local area that 26
degrees slope constant slope built-in
moguls from small craters that are
formed on the surface I think it'd be a
great ski area one of these days 7,000
foot vertical dropped one swell foop
that's not too bad this is what things
look like after we had worked around the
lunar module for a while and the rover
is parked there in its best position for
thermal control a lot of the thermal
control was passive try to keep things
as cool as we possibly could but not too
cold because I should I guess I should
mention that say a surface like that and
direct sunlight would be probably at to
250 degrees C whereas in the shadow any
shadow there the surface would very
quickly be down at about a minus 150
degrees C so the tremendous temperature
contrasts between light and and shadow
depending of course on the absorptivity
emissivity ratio of the particular
surface but one reason for showing this
picture is to is to illustrate the
nature of that debris layer the regolith
in which our resources are contained and
it's a lot like damp beach sand it takes
a very nice footprint if you're if you
careful with it you see these show up
very nicely but you gradually will stir
it up it's slightly cohesive when you
scuff it you get a little bit of dust
but you also get some clots that spray
out from your boot but gradually even
though it has a very high in the
undisturbed area out here it has a very
high bearing strength no problem at all
driving or walking over it as you stir
it up of course it starts to lose that
bearing strength and that's an issue for
those of you that someday will design or
live at a lunar base you'll have to make
sure that that somehow you you may you
create a surface on the regolith
possibly with just aggregate that
doesn't end up being a problem for the
long term
Jeanne took this picture as we were
preparing to leave after our 75 hour
stay and twenty-two hours outside the
spacecraft both records I might presume
to say pilots like to keep records you
know and so I'm reminded of that many
times the you see yours truly preparing
to go up the ladder with a bag full of
samples as any good geologist should and
hugene however was on his way out to
park the rover so it could watch our our
essent back into lunar orbit which if
i'm not mistaken it will be the picture
after this one this is a picture out the
right hand window again after we had
completed our adventures looking towards
the science station which is deployed
out in that area about 300 meters away
the tracks of the rover and yours truly
walk running back more skiing actually
back and forth cross-country ski
technique works very well on the moon
you can move at ten maybe even fifteen
kilometers an hour if you if you work at
it it stopping is another problem but it
still you can you could by gliding just
over the surface rather than on it you
do very well the asset is not well
photographed and I apologize for that
this has taken off of a television
monitor gene tried to persuade me to go
outside and get a really good picture of
liftoff
but I was developing some political
astuteness even at that point and we
were we were on our way whoops can we
turn that one back somebody apparently I
had to give a number of that picture to
somebody the other night and I
apparently didn't I can great thank you
this at this point I just want to
summarize with this picture some of the
historical significance of our
activities I've already mentioned to you
that in the history of science we
developed a first-order understanding of
a small planet chemically very much like
our own with many geological
relationships to our own planet but this
was done now by Apollo for the first
time and that's and it's a very
significant and detailed scientific
understanding of that planet and has
implications for our understanding of
our own planet particularly its early
history and and particularly the origins
of life on this planet the astronaut and
in this case yours truly with Gene
Cernan reflected in my visor symbolizes
for the in the history of Technology one
of the if not the greatest explosions of
know-how that technology has seen and
although done in the in a spirit if you
will of competition with the former
Soviet Union nevertheless was done
without a direct threat of war and and
that technology base is benefiting
continues to benefit us today in many
many different ways the flag of the
United States symbolizes not only what
the country did in and of itself in
response to the challenge that was
perceived at the time from the former
Soviet Union but also represents really
what free men and women can do when
faced with the challenge that they
believe in and believe is the most and
meet believe the meeting of that
challenge is the most important thing
they can do with their lives I'm sure
you all have heard and maybe even use
the phrase well if you can go to the
moon why can't you and then you fill in
the blank no the point is that you can
do whatever you put into that blank if
it's a big if
if you can motivate young men and women
like yourselves to believe that that's
the most important they can do with
their lives at that point in time it may
turn out that later on they have second
feelings about it but nevertheless if
the belief is there at the time you can
do almost anything in fact I don't know
what is what is beyond us if we have
those kind of beliefs and finally in the
history of the human species symbolized
by the earth above the flag and more
appropriately maybe symbolized by this
view of the earth rising from behind the
moon we now have both the technological
and psychological awareness I think to
move the human species into space there
are resources that can serve the
environment of the earth on the moon
particularly as we search in the
not-too-distant future for that
necessary of alternative to fossil fuels
there are the resources additional
resources on the moon that can make
human enclaves there self-sufficient the
same applies to Mars and if we have any
kind of long-term and I mean long-term
species survival instinct then the
enclaves of the human species on those
two planets are going to be
extraordinarily important to us as well
as what they do to enable the earth
indeed to survive itself and so Apollo
has given us that new opportunity what
we do with that literally new
evolutionary status is probably very
difficult to say at this point but
nevertheless as a result of the efforts
of Apollo including some people in this
room here today many people in this room
here today we we now have options that
we never had before and wouldn't have
without it now let's digress as we walk
off the stage here and digress a bit to
the science by itself before Apollo and
at the end of the so-called unmanned
I've literally automated lunar
exploration program we had a general
understanding of the evolution of the
moon it that there was a very old and
highly cratered crust that it had been
it had been modified by large circular
impact basins some more circular than
others the highland they're highland
basins were filled with some
light-colored smooth plains we didn't
understand and by the way still don't
today there were almost basaltic lava
flows in most of the basins on the near
side of the moon there were additional
volcanic deposits that look like they
had been pyroclastic that is the kind of
fire fountains that we see today on the
Island of Hawaii and elsewhere around
the planet and that there was this deep
layer of pulverized debris the regolith
covering all of this that had developed
through the some unknown period of time
since these other events occurred now
after apollo we added a great deal of
detail particularly we we we understand
now the timeframe in which these things
had happened the earth the moon
basically began within the limits of
measurement error at the same time the
earth began about four and a half
billion years ago almost 4.6 billion
years ago and and that is now taken with
the meteorite data as the age of the
solar system itself there early in its
history right at the beginning near the
beginning there was a magma ocean
literally the outer probably five
hundred kilometers of the moon was
molten are largely molten so that it
differentiated that is as it
crystallized like crystals floated and
heavy crystals sank and it in and so you
ended up with a crust made up largely of
a light mineral called a North acidic
felspar anorthosite is what the rock
name is used and underneath that is a
mantle
the moon that is composed largely of
olivine and pyroxene and anytime I talk
about this now you have to put in your
own minds was that happening on the
earth the answer is almost certainly yes
that these events were reflected on
comparable events on the earth the earth
being modified by its ability to with
withhold a fluid sphere
whereas the moon could not but
nevertheless we we we now have to think
in terms of these events or comparable
events having occurred on the earth as
well following the solidification of the
magma ocean after maybe a hundred
million years or less the highlands
begin to retain the evidence of the
intense cratering that was going on
indeed the highland areas of the moon
are saturated with craters at least 80
kilometers in diameter that is
mathematically saturated with craters of
that side an unbelievable period of
violence as the in the waning stages of
the formation of the solar system and
then at some point probably beginning
about 4.2 billion years ago large basins
begin to form the the the old large
basins are the irregular ones and the
newer ones the younger ones still very
old 3.9 billion years old or so are
circular and that implies in itself that
during that period of time the crust was
somehow strengthened that is an area of
debate now of how how did that crustal
strengthening occur but there has been
there has been isostatic that is
compensation of the the gravity
anomalies it would have been associated
with these large basins there has not
been compensation of the younger basins
so something strengthened the crust at
that point so those those anomalies
could last for three almost four billion
years in this period of time the you the
the extrusion of the basaltic lavas in
the Maurya reached its peak and
continued for at least a billion years
we don't know exactly how long
occurred and then after that things
pretty well stopped if you had been
around three billion years ago and been
able to look at the moon you would have
seen roughly what we see today a few
there would been bright craters they've
been different than the ones you see
today but nevertheless they would have
been there and during that three billion
years this mature Regulus surface
developed and began to accumulate solar
wind bottles and mostly hydrogen quite a
bit of helium and then of course as part
of the helium the helium three that is
of some interest to us now from an
energy perspective and an environmental
perspective so that is is a we of course
also understand a great deal about the
interior of the Moon as a result of the
seismic experiments we know it's roughly
its Laird character and and from other
constraints pretty much what it's
composed of today so again I we did
learn a tremendous amount about the the
moon and its history and the history of
the earth as a consequence I think I'm
going to leave it there if I could have
the lights and if there's time for some
questions I'll be happy to take those
thank you very much
we have time for questions okay
questions yes
well first question does it invoked when
I see it in the sky doesn't invoke
emotions I add must because I notice it
more than I remember noticing the moon I
mean it it catches my eye and that's the
best I can say if I go around a building
suddenly I see the moon where I'm sure
I'd prior to being involved in the
Apollo program I didn't see it or didn't
recognize my are in the monument vally
it'll suddenly it's there by the side of
a one of the the mesas and you know I
just notice it but as far as any major
change as a result of actually going to
the moon I I have to say I don't think
there was a change in my but the
maturing experience of ten years
actually more closer to eight years of
direct involvement in in in a
environment in which everyone was
totally dedicated to success of this
particular project that was that had a
tremendous influence on life not only my
life but my perspectives of what human
beings are capable of doing as I
indicated earlier when challenged and
when they believed in the challenge I
had an advantage over many of the other
astronauts although the vast majority of
them went on to very challenging careers
primarily in business but in some other
arenas as well I also had my science and
part of my transition was based on
working on the lunar samples and trying
to synthesize which I still spend some
time on today the results of the Apollo
science program and so that that kept me
moving at the same time some old friends
of Bob Siemens in mine George George
Lowe and Jim Fletcher asked me if and I
may have stimulated the question but
nevertheless they asked me if I would
come to
NASA headquarters - to work on the
transfer of NASA technologies into
energy related activities you see this
all was occurring about the same time as
the era first Arab oil embargo in 1973
and that it occurred to all of us that
there might be a great deal of
application for NASA technologies Apollo
technologies in the energy field and
indeed I think there there were and
there have been maybe not as much as I
had hoped at the time but I worked on
that for a couple years and and I had
always had in the back of my mind from
the time I was a graduate student really
at Harvard in the 1960s that getting
into politics was something that I
probably would look at very seriously
and I began to look at that seriously
while I was in Washington in 74 75 and
decided to go back to New Mexico and my
home state and run for the Senate and
that there was never any time in there
to sit back and say gee what am I gonna
do next there was always something on
the rise and and I just would have to
say to you that no matter what goals you
set for yourself and I think some of the
astronauts fell victim to this no matter
what goals you set for yourself keep
them in context with your whole life if
it's the only thing you have as a goal
in your life and you're not thinking
about the future at all beyond that then
whether you achieve it or don't achieve
it you're going to be at sea for a while
and I think some of the astronauts
discovered that was the case after
they'd been to the moon the post Apollo
an article in Scientific American the
summer science legacy and it laid out
the evidence that said now we have
confidence that the origin of the moon
was the result of a major impact comet
comet impact on the earth which released
this large mass that became the moon and
this was followed up by a flood of
letters in the preceding months and a
month
disputing that do you have any thoughts
on school I wish I'd written one of
those letters because I disputed as well
there is you can perform some fantastic
computer models that make that a
plausible hypothesis unfortunately I
think there is at least one major bit of
geological evidence that that model has
a very difficult time explaining and it
goes back it has to do with the orange
soil that I mentioned briefly earlier
the orange soil was volcanic material
pyroclastic like the fire fountains from
Hawaii there is strong geologic and
experimental evidence utilizing the
orange soil that that came from from
deep within the moon some components of
it came from below that 500 kilometers
of lunar melting and it indicates that
below that depth the the moon is largely
undifferentiated that is its primordial
material for example the lead that
isotopic composition in in that that's
associated with that orange soil and it
comes from those depths is what we call
parent as parentless lead I mean it's
it's primordial lead it doesn't have a
great radioactive component to it as as
you would expect from other thing it
also has volatile elements that are are
depleted in this part of the moon that
was molten at one time and they're
concentrated in this in the gases that
apparently drove this volcanic eruption
and it's very difficult I won't go into
all the details but it's very very
difficult for me and I have not seen a
rational explanation from the proponents
of the Mahr sized asteroid theory of how
you explain having a relatively
undifferentiated interior the moon if it
was knocked off it largely
differentiated earth I don't I just
don't know how that works and so I'm a
skeptic of that model it's a good one
play it stimulated an awful lot of
discussion that's what's is what's fun
about science is developing the models
and seeing if they work and more often
than not they don't and you go on to the
next one in this case I think that we
still have some explaining to do and so
I tend to favor if you say okay what's
your idea I think that the it's probably
a capture phenomenon that when all the
evidence is in that will find that the
moon was was derived in the vicinity of
the earth because of its overall
silicate dominated composition but that
it was in a separate solar orbit and but
one close enough and Earth crossing
orbit and eventually was captured and it
turns out that although in the early
days the the calculations indicated that
was a very very very mathematically a
very special case it now does not look
like it's quite so special there some
the work on capture by a few people has
now indicated that there probably a
number of different ways in which it
could be captured into an Earth orbit
and so that's where I'm leaning right
now is in that direction it helps to
explain a lot of things that I don't
think the Mars crossbar sized asteroid
will explain yes sir
depending on the level of the solar
particle event we would try to put as
much mass as we could between us in the
event that was the only plan we had we
knew that that was one of the major
risks to the health and safety of the
Apollo crews and and there was not any
planning beyond that although there was
extensive planning to how to anticipate
what was was worked into the contingency
plans based on what part of the mission
the event occurred you would then move
to get as much mass between you and that
event as possible and you know
ultimately meant you'd get into the
command module as fast as you could
because that's the that would have the
most mass and so if we were on the
surface we would try to get off the
surface as soon as we possibly could in
rendezvous with the command
there is still some debate over that at
the time it was felt that it was about
an hour although some people who still
study that problem suggest that maybe
only about thirty minutes and I can't
tell you why there's that factor of two
discrepancy I have they've not been able
to explain it to me and I can't explain
it to you but there is that kind of a
debate going on about it but it's not
much now knowing what I know now there
there probably was a very easy solution
to the lunar surface flare problem and
that is to use a linear shaped charge
explosive charge to create a trench
drive the lunar rover over it
and have some capability to to at least
pile dirt pile regolith on top of that
Rover that would be a very good way to
deal with the mass issue and just live
off you know by cutting down your the
rate at which you're working you could
live off your consumables for a number
of hours longer under that rover than
you would have if you were working now
you could augment that solution by
having some additional consumables on
the rover that you then could attach to
with a vacuum transfer into your suit
all of those things are feasible in as a
matter of fact as we look towards lunar
bases I personally think that's probably
the way you'll you'll deal with that
continued hazard and the risk associated
with it is to have those kinds of
systems worked out in advance so I don't
think in the long run it needs to be a
major issue for actually a permanent
work permanent test activities on the
moon
well I both of them I just was a
principal investigator on a proposal for
the discovery program to put a lunar
rover a new Rover automated Rover on the
surface of the moon to get a better
three-dimensional understanding of the
lunar regolith scientific understanding
the regular not only for science in many
different ways but also to better
understand how to design future habitats
machines and things like that that would
operate on and within the regular so I
feel very strongly that you need to find
the right balance but at some point
you'll always find me feeling very
strongly that that the integration of
robotic or automated technology and
human capabilities is the is ultimately
the way to get the the greatest return
on the buck spent and I just write a
part it's partly my nature
I hope it's partly a good logical
position to be in I just don't see how
we can fully scientifically our
humanistically take advantage of the
opportunities that are available to us
in space without the combination and
particularly without the presence of
human beings at some point in that in
that pyramid the the argument will go on
I have heard people and including my
good friend Carl Sagan say that
everything we learned on Apollo could
have been learned with an automated
system while giving that but he's never
had to cost that out and I just have a
strong gut feeling as an earth scientist
to get that level of understanding of
the history of a small planet purely
through automated missions would have
cost you at least as much in linear
dollars as the Apollo program cost and
I'm not sure would have been possible
with the technologies that were
available
well then now we have a somewhat
different picture the what you can gain
with some of the advanced imaging and
analytical mass spectrometry
particularly technologies that we could
put on a rover automated Rover on the
moon is far and above what we could have
done 25 years ago but still I think the
the arguments are useful one because it
makes everybody think but the other side
shall I say if I'm on the man side has
never really had to cost out all of
these sayings that dark that a human
being can do went on there when they're
when they're left when a trained and
experienced human being can do when
they're put into their own environment
in space you ask the closing question I
was going to ask so with that I will
thank Jack Schmidt for a lecture that
will remember perhaps until we see the
next man on the moon Thank You pleasure
[Applause]